AUSTIN ROBISON: All right.
Good morning, everybody.
It's great to see a really
packed house in here.
It looks like
standing room only.
We're really excited
today to talk
to you guys about Android Wear.
I'm Austin Robison.
I'm a product manager
with the team.
JUSTIN KOH: And I'm Justin Koh.
I'm an engineering
lead on the team.
AUSTIN ROBISON: Excellent.
And we have been so
thrilled with the excitement
that we've gotten from you
guys throughout the rest
of the conference.
I think the third floor
area where the devices
are out there has been
mobbed the entire time that I
have walked by.
So thank you for
all of your support,
and we're really excited
to talk about what
we're doing with Android Wear.
So I wanted to start with
a quick overview of what
Android Wear is all about.
And we'll dive into some
code and really show you
what it's like to build
applications for Wear.
So we all love our smartphones.
They're rich and
engaging, and they
can deliver these are really
deep engrossing experiences.
But I think this is a picture
that we can all relate to,
sitting around, we're all
focusing on our phones
and not on the people around us.
So technology can
be distracting,
and here's where we saw an
opportunity with Android Wear
to make this better.
Android Wear delivers
information just when
you need it and
just in a glance.
And really, that means
you can be more connected
to the people around
you and the people who
aren't with you at that time.
So if you look at
that in a timeline,
this is something that I
think we have all experienced.
You feel your phone buzz in
your pockets, you pull it out,
and you're like, OK, well, I got
some email notifications here.
You go to your inbox,
and next thing you know,
you spend several
minutes distracted
from the world around
you, really engaged
with what you're doing,
but not necessarily
present with what's going on.
So with Android Wear and having
these glanceable notifications
on your wrist, you can have more
interaction throughout the day,
have them shorter
and less distracting
from the world
around you, but still
get more information
about what's happening.
So to deliver this
new interaction model,
we created an entirely new UI.
Now, what that is is a
vertical stream of contextually
ranked cards.
So you have the most
important information for you
at the top of the
stream, ready for you
to glance down and
take a look at it.
This is completely automated
from a Android perspective
of having your notifications
bridged across.
It also has Google Now
cards, and importantly, it
has your third
party content, which
is what we're going to
be talking about today.
So earlier this
year, we launched
a developer preview
that allowed you to get
started experimenting
with your apps of what
it would be like to bring
your experience to the wrist.
So this allowed you to take
your notification objects
on your phone and really
be able to augment
them to have additional
pages of information,
to be able to bundle these
things together in stacks,
and to be able to
have voice replies.
So what we're making
available today
is an SDK that allows you to
extend those experiences even
further, where you're
running code directly
on the wearable using all of
the familiar Android tools
that you are already
used to using.
So we're going to
introduce a few APIs that
allow you to send data back
and forth between the wearable
and your phone, as well
as generate custom UI
and integrate with Voice Actions
through intent filtering,
just like on the phone.
So we've been battle
testing these APIs
with dozens of third
party partners.
And we've had some really
great apps be created.
You've seen several of them
featured in the keynote.
You've seen several of
them in previous sessions.
I'm going to walk
through a couple more
here, just to give you an idea
of the types of things that
are now possible with this SDK.
So Runtastic is a
social fitness platform.
And their Wear integration helps
users control those sessions
from their wrist.
So you can say, OK,
Google, start running.
And they'll post a notification
to that stream that
has a running timer
of your current run.
They can also show new
UI inside of these cards
with a new platform feature
called Display Intents that
allow you to embed
an activity directly
into these cards for
drawing your own UI.
On the right here
we also see a piece
of data that was generated
in the phone, which
is your route that can
be synchronized across
automatically.
And we'll go into the
details of how you do that.
Another example, Philips Hue.
They are connected
light bulbs that
allow you to change their
colors from your phone.
There's a display out
on the third floor
here, really fantastic.
Maybe they're down on
the second floor, sorry.
And what their app does
is when you come home,
it posts this contextual
card to the stream
that allows you to then
control your lighting.
They also can launch
a full screen activity
to draw their own UI to have
a more immersive experience
while you're
controlling that app,
and then get back to the stream.
So important to note here is
that we're really focusing apps
around micro interactions.
So we want users to be able
to get into your feature,
complete a task,
and then get back
to that stream as
quickly as possible.
If there's an action that
requires deeper integration,
we want to forward that
user back to the phone.
And we've also made
that very easy for you.
One more example
here, Glympse, which
is a social location
sharing application.
So you can send your
location to your friends.
On the wearable, we can
send contact information
from your phone across, so you
can have a list of contacts
to look through to be able
to send those locations.
When you receive a Glympse, you
can also then see in real time
the progress of your
friend coming to you.
So let's take a
look at what we're
going to be looking at for
the rest of the talk here.
So Justin just got this
adorable new puppy,
and so we've built a little
slide control app here
for showing some
pictures of that puppy.
So we've got a phone
and a wearable up here.
When we start on
this slide show,
we can post a notification to
the stream on the right here.
As you scroll through the
ViewPager on the left,
we're updating in
real time on the right
the title of the slide, as well
as the number of the slide.
We also have an action that
allows you to go backwards.
Tapping on that first
piece also allows
you to advance the
slides on the phone.
So we're using it
as a remote control.
And we're using all
of these new APIs
to provide a seamless
experience across both devices.
So if we take a look
at what it takes
to build this
application, when we write
an app for a phone or
a tablet, typically we
have one APK per app.
But with Android Wear,
we're extending that concept
to expand across both devices.
So we have an APK that
runs directly on the phone,
and we have an APK
that runs directly
on the wearable that are
both part of your app.
Google Play services is
what brings these two things
together and where we're going
to talk about a new set of APIs
that allow you to send
data between the two
and facilitate
that communication.
So the wearable services consist
of three APIs, a Data API,
a Message API, and a Node API.
These are both callable
from either side, so
from the wearable
or from the phone.
And all of your data is
private to your application
across the link.
So if we dig into here first
and look at the Node API,
this is used for
discovering when
nodes come into and out
of a connected state.
So when we have a
pairing established
between a watch and
a phone, for example,
we can be notified when we
come into connection range.
So you might use
this in your app
to know when a wearable is
present to toggle features
on and off.
We might display an
icon to show that you're
connected to a wearable.
It's a very simple
API for just being
aware of when the
wearable is present.
Built on top of that
is the Message API.
So this is a low
latency mechanism
for sending byte arrays back
and forth between the devices.
And they can be
filtered on pads,
which Justin will
explain in detail later.
So in the puppy
example, when we are
tapping on the
card in the stream
or tapping that Back
button to go backwards,
we're calling sendMessage to
send a simple control back
to the phone, which
receives that message
and then moves the ViewPager.
The Data API is
the biggest piece
of this new wearable service.
It's a replicated data store.
You can think about
it as a shared cache.
So we have the ability
to put data into this,
and take data out
of it, be notified
when it changes on either
side, and we take care
of synchronizing that
data between devices.
So you don't need to worry about
devices that are intermittently
connected, what to do
when you have extended
periods of not being connected.
We do all of the
hard work there.
And all you have to do from
the outside is put data
into the store and take it out.
So in the puppy
example, we might
put the title of the slide
and that slide number
into the store.
Google Play services
replicates that
across to the wearable,
where we can then
update that notification
in real time.
So we can have the data
sent back and forth there.
So now I'm going
to turn things over
to Justin for a
little bit, who's
going to walk us
through using these APIs
and really dig into
some of the code, which
I know you're all excited about.
Take it away, Justin.
JUSTIN KOH: Thanks
a lot, Austin.
Whoa, little drinking
problem there.
So you'll have to excuse me.
We just got our new puppy, and
I'm incredibly allergic to her.
So I've developed
a bit of a cough.
So if you see me
about to go like this,
everyone kinda ear muffs.
So let's take a look at the
overall building blocks that
are going to make
up our application.
On the left-hand
side here, we see
we have our ViewPager that's
going to have a couple
fragments, these
slide fragments.
And when the user slides
from left to right,
we're going to
update our data item.
We're going to update
the index from 1 to 2.
We push this into
the data store.
And that event is going to
get over to the wearable.
And we're going to update a
notification when that happens.
So to begin, we need to
download Android Studio
and create a new project.
So I've created a new project
here called Slide Control.
You can see that Android Studio
now supports multiple form
factors, all the form factors
that we talked about yesterday.
Wear is one of those.
So you just click
the check box here,
and Android Studio is going
to take care of packaging up
this glanceable portion of
your APK, or this watch APK,
into your phone application
so that it can be distributed
through the Play Store.
Let's start by setting
up the phone UI.
So like I said, this
activity is ViewPager,
and it has a couple
fragments in it,
with the background
image, title of the slide.
And these are all the
files that make up
the two different applications.
Again, on the left, we've got
the phone APK files in green.
On the right, we've got the
wearable APK files in blue.
Let's take a look at the
presentation activity.
And this is the ViewPager one.
And we can see that the
first thing we need to do
is to create a
Google API client.
That's your entry point into all
of these Google Play services.
So the new API here
is the Wearable API.
So I'm going to build
my client and stash it
away somewhere so I can use
it throughout my application's
life cycle.
Next thing I want to do
is wire up my ViewPager
so that when those
events happen,
we can update the Data Store.
And I do that by creating
an OnPageChangedListener
and calling updateDataItem.
Let's take a look at data items.
So like we said, URIs are
everything in this Data API.
And we do that because
it's really easy
to create them and parse them
using existing Android classes.
So in this case, I am
creating a data item
that's going to
manage the state.
What is the current index
and the current title
of the presentation
slide that I'm on?
So I create this /state path.
And internally, the Data API
is going to create this fully
qualified URI, wear://,
nodeid, and state.
Now, you don't have to
worry about that as much
as developers.
You can just worry about
the paths, et cetera.
But knowing that this
is the format of the URI
will help you later
when it comes time
to reconstitute these
URIs on the other side.
Data items are byte
arrays at their base,
but we know that
working with byte arrays
can be not that flexible.
It's really nice to be able
to work at the key value pair
level, like a bundle.
So we've created
a key value pair
object called the Data Map,
which stores primitive types.
Unlike a bundle, we
won't be storing anything
like parcelables
or binders in there
because this item
is going to be sent
to all of the nodes
in our network.
So in this case, I
create a data map,
and I'm going to put in
these primitive types--
the current index, the
total number of slides,
and the title of the
current slide we're on.
Finally, I just insert
it into the store.
And it's going to
get synchronized
to all of the connected nodes.
On the wearable side, we want
to be able to receive this.
And we want to be running
a service to do so.
Now, we don't want all of
the different applications
to have to be running constant
services all the time just
to listen for a message.
And so what we've done is we've
created this abstract class,
the WearableListenerService,
which
implements all of the
different callback methods
that you're going to be using
with these wearable APIs.
That's NodeListener,
MessageListener,
and DataListener.
So I have subclassed
this here in
a PresentationListenerService,
and I just
insert that into my
Android manifest.
By doing so, the Google
Play services APK
is going to manage the life
cycle of this service for me
so it's not always
running and consuming
resources, precious
resources, on my wearable.
Let's go over here to
PresentationListenerSerivce.
And you'll see that the
DataListener interface
has one method, OnDataChanged.
When I get that, I'm going to
check the path because there
may be multiple messages
in my application.
And I want to make
sure I'm doing
the right thing with
the right data item.
So if the state, remember
we set this up as the state,
is the data item's
path, then I'm
going to either create or
update the notification,
if it's just being changed.
And if it's being
deleted, I want
to remove that notification
from the stream
because it's no longer
relevant to the user.
In handleStateChanged, we're
going to extract our data map.
We're going to get all of
those primitives out of there,
and we're going to
post our notification.
Now, I know this
is a lot of code.
I'm going to walk
through it step by step.
What are the things
that we want to do?
We want to get an intent
back into our service
when the user taps
that first card.
So to do so, it's
just like Android.
I'm going to create a
PendingIntent to our service.
And I'm going to use an
action on this intent
to determine what
the user wants to do.
Do they want to
advance the slide,
or do they want to go previous?
Next thing I'm going
to do is create
a NotificationManagerCompat
object,
which is in the support library.
So building this
basic notification
is just like building a
notification on the phone.
I've got my title.
I've got my text.
And like Austin
said, we're going
to setOngoing because this
represents an ongoing process.
Finally, we're going to augment
or extend our notification
with the new APIs that exist
in the support library.
So I'm going to create
a new action which
will be the advance action.
By default, if I were to
have created a content
intent, on Android Wear we would
render this as a blue circle.
But if you notice
from the demos,
we wanted to be able to just tap
the card and advance the slide.
So I've created my action
here with a drawable and just
some text.
And I've called
setContentAction.
That's going to hoist that
action on to the card.
And if you remember from
the design talk that you
may have seen,
Designing for Wearables,
we're going to want to
make that icon blue so
that the user knows that
they can tap the card.
That's going to be the signal.
When they see blue, that's
an actionable thing.
Finally, we extend our builder.
And that's going to create
that notification that you see.
Now of course, with
even more code,
we can add in the
previous action.
We just create a different
intent with a different action,
with a different
action on the intent,
and then we create a different
action on the notification
itself.
So as a reward for getting
through all that code,
here's a picture of a puppy.
So on the phone
side, we're going
to want to receive
some messages.
So first of all, we have
to send the message.
So in this case,
we're going to see
that I'm going to tap on
the Previous Slide button,
and it's going to go back there.
And that's still going to be
in PresentationListenerService.
Remember, when that
pending intent fires,
it's going to come
back into our service.
And check what is the action
of the intent that came in.
And I'm going to
just send a control
message using the Message API.
So I take a Google
API client where
I've added the Wearable API, and
I'm just going to send 1 byte.
So it's either going to be 0
to go forward or 1 to go back.
And I'm going to send this to
a specific node, the node that
owns the data item.
Remember, I can
get this by parsing
the path of the data item.
And I'm going to send this on
its own specific path, which
we're going to call
the control path.
Over on the phone side, we make
ViewPresentationActivity also
implement a
MessageListener interface.
That means that it's
going to implement
this onMessageReceived.
So if it is a control message,
we just take that first byte
and we decide whether we're
going to advance the slide
or go to the previous slide.
When that happens, we
update the ViewPager.
We just call setCurrentItem
on the ViewPager.
And then that's going to fire
the OnPageChangeListener, which
will update the data item and
come all the way back around.
So this is a really
good pattern.
You want to make sure that your
data items are sort of owned
by one of the nodes
in your system.
In this case, the data
item is owned by the phone.
We could have tried to edit
it on the wearable side
and have that synchronize
back and forth.
That gets a little messy.
It's much better to do data
item owned buy one of the nodes,
and then you send
messages to update it,
and then you just have
this virtuous cycle
going around and around.
So as we see here, when
we get our message,
we are going to just go
back to the previous slide.
So let's talk a little bit
about extending this use case.
Now, if I'm giving a
longer presentation,
it might be good to have this
notification in the stream.
I want my watch to be able to
timeout back to the home screen
so I'm not burning power.
But if I'm giving a
much shorter, a more
condensed presentation,
I would maybe
want to control what activity
is on top so that, as a user,
I can just kind of slide
around and not really
have to worry about
what I'm doing.
And to do this, I'm going to
create a custom activity that's
running on the wearable.
Let's take a look at that.
So in the slide we
see we can slide over,
and we have another action
here called the Full screen.
And when I tap on it,
I'm going to bring up
a activity on the wearable
that has a ViewPager.
And these are synchronized.
So when I swipe over
here, it's going
to update the ViewPager
running on the phone.
It also has some
other things that I
might want for my presentation
like the current time,
and maybe I want to go red
when I'm going over time,
or things like that.
So let's talk about how to
get this data, the image
and the titles, over
to the wearable.
We want to use the data layer.
We want to do it efficiently.
We could just keep updating
our state data item,
but that means that
every time it changes,
we're going to have
to send all that data
over and over and over again.
So instead, I'm going to store
my data in several data items.
And they're each going to
have their own unique path.
So it's going to be wear://, the
node ID, then slide/ the index.
And so you can see here I've
got three different data items.
And over here on
the wearable, I use
that to inflate some card
fragments for my activity.
We're going to call this
the SlideControlActivity.
So let's see how we do that.
In our SlideControlActivity,
we have a very simple layout.
It's just a ViewPager.
But remember, I
want to make sure
that this doesn't timeout
to the home screen.
And I do that by setting
android:keepScreenOn to true.
Again, just like you
would do on a phone
if you had some sort of
media playing application.
Now, remember, with great power
comes great responsibility.
You want to be kind
to people's batteries.
You don't want to
be in a situation
where the user might
accidentally end up
in this full screen activity
and it doesn't efficiently
go to sleep.
So we want to watch out for--
with keepScreenOn, you probably
want to keep track of
the user's timeout.
You might want to
make it settable.
And if the user
hasn't interacted
with the device for a
certain period of time,
just finish your activity.
We also want to key activities
to a user's context.
So remember, with
PresentationListenerService,
when the users finished viewing
the slide show on their phone,
we removed the notification.
Similarly, when the users
finished viewing the slide show
on their phone, we also
want to exit this activity
if it's running.
And the final note is to
watch out for wakelocks.
It's very important on wearables
with the smaller battery
capacity to just
really be cognizant
of your users' batteries.
So let's take a look over
here in SlideControlActivity.
And we've set this
up very much like
the PresentationListenerService.
So we've got our
handleStateChanged method here.
We're going to extract
our presentation data,
and we're just going to
set the ViewPager that's
running on the wearable
to be the same index
as the index on the phone.
We also want to be able to
control it from the wearable.
So I create another
OnPageChangedListener,
and now I'm going to send a
different type of message.
Instead of that control
forward and backwards message,
I'm going to send a
new type of message
on a different
path called slide.
And here the byte is
just going to say,
what is the desired index
that I want to have?
Back on the phone side in
the ViewPresentaionActivity,
if I see the message coming
in on the slide path,
then I'm going to parse
that out from the byte,
and I'm just going
to send it there.
Once again, I will then trigger
the OnPageChangedListener,
which will trigger Update Item,
and everything goes around.
Virtuous cycle.
And here we see the
results of that.
There we go.
So by default, Android
Wear activities
can be dismissed by
swiping left to right.
This even works
with our ViewPager.
If we swipe over a few
times and swipe back,
everything works
the way you expect.
When I'm on the first slide,
if I swipe from left to right,
I'm going to dismiss
that activity.
But remember, I'm in the middle
of a high stakes presentation
here, and I don't want
to accidentally do
that if I'm moving around.
So when we want to
override that behavior,
it's definitely possible.
And it's possible without
a line of Java code.
It's just updating a style
and your Android manifest.
So we come over
here, and you create
a theme in your
application that inherits
from the device default theme.
We're still running
KitKat on the wearable,
and so we don't have
these material themes yet.
So we're Theme.DeviceDefault.
You should definitely use
those in your applications.
We have a new
attribute here called
android:windowSwipeToDismiss.
By setting this to
false, you're going
to do disable that
default behavior of being
able to swipe an activity away.
Then I just set that as
my theme in the activity.
Now, I don't want the user to
get locked into my activity,
though.
They should know how to get out.
By default, all
Android Wear devices,
you can put your
palm on the screen
to go back to the home screen,
but that's not necessarily
as elegant as we'd like to do.
We'd like to establish a
pattern for these full screen
applications.
And what we've come up
with is a long press.
So when you long
press, we're going
to bring up this red circle.
And then if you tap it, we're
going to finish the activity.
We've created a support class
to make it very easy for you
to do this in your
own applications.
So I'm going to
update my layouts,
and I'm going to create
a DismissOverlayView so
that it just hangs out on top.
And it's going to be
hidden by default.
Over here in
SlideControlActivity,
I just need to get a
reference to that overlay view
and then use a GestureDetector.
I could've used a
long click listener
if I had a different
type of view,
but with ViewPager, it's easier
to use a GestureDetector.
So again, just like
using it on the phone,
I create a GestureDetector.
I'm going to feed
motion events to it,
and when I get the
long press, I'll
show my DismissOverlayView.
DismissOverlayView is going to
take care of everything else.
When the user taps on it, it's
going to exit the activity
and go back to the stream.
Final thing we
want to talk about
are assets-- getting picture
data over to the wearable.
Obviously, that's
what we're going
to want to do to create these
rich, awesome experiences
for our users.
So everything that
we're doing is
in the name of
efficiency-- efficiency
for battery life, et cetera.
So let's say I had an app
that used a contact photo.
That's a very common use case.
And say that
somebody else wanted
to use that exact
same contact photo.
Well, we don't want to have
to transmit multiple copies.
So by putting these assets
into our data layer,
we will take a hash and
only send one copy over.
Now on the other
side of the link,
these applications don't really
know that another application
was using that same asset.
They just see it as
their own private copy.
So it's all secure.
It's all there.
It's great.
We're going to use those
assets with our puppy app,
although who else is going to
be using pictures of my puppy?
We're going to want to not send
the full resolution image over,
however.
So the resolution on the
Nexus 5 is much higher
than the one on the wearable.
So I'm going to want
to make sure that only
I'm sending the
image data that's
necessary for display
on a smaller device.
So to do that, we go into
ViewPresentationActivity.
And here we're going
to call this function
for each of the slides
in our presentation.
I'll probably do this
in an asynchronous task
when I'm loading it up.
I'm going to create my
data items at a known URI,
so in this case slide/index.
I'm going to put the title in.
And now I'm going
to create an asset.
All of my slide objects
know how to create
a smaller version of themselves,
just as a byte array.
From there, I send that
to Asset.createFromBytes,
and I put it into the map.
And then it's going to
intelligently send that over
to the wearable.
On the wearable side in
the SlideControlActivity,
I'm going to again use an
asynchronous task, or a loader,
to load this up.
And here's where we see the
importance of the paths.
Since I know that it's going
to be wear:// et cetera,
I can send these URIs around
and build upon them in order
to derive queries
for these data items.
And so here I'm going to load
up each of the different data
items from the data layer.
I'm going to extract the asset.
And from those bytes, I'm
going to create a bitmap
that I can then use
to update my UI.
And that's what we got.
So now I'm going to
turn it back to Austin.
AUSTIN ROBISON: All right.
Thank you, Justin.
[APPLAUSE]
So we hope that's given
you a taste of what's
possible with these new APIs
and with this new form factor
and has sparked some
ideas for your own apps,
or maybe even new apps.
So we're all very excited to
see what you go and create.
For more information,
you guys can visit
developer.android.com/wear,
download the SDK,
and get started there.
There's an emulator.
You can use it with the devices
that you got at the giveaway.
And you can get started there.
We also have even more
information about these APIs
available as I/O Bytes.
Those are up on
YouTube right now.
You can go check them out.
And with that, we will thank
you, and we'll take questions.
There's microphones right
in the aisle ways here.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that the wearable leverages
the Google Play services.
So does this mean
that we can't connect
to Kindle devices and
that kind of thing?
AUSTIN ROBISON:
So the connection
is driven by Google
Play services.
So we are compatible with
any Android device running
4.3 or greater with
the Play Store.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUSTIN ROBISON: Let's
go to this side.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Is it possible to leave your
custom activity on and let
the device go to sleep,
or does that automatically
exit to the home screen when
the wakelock is released?
JUSTIN KOH: It's going
to automatically time out
after 30 seconds
to the home screen.
AUDIENCE: Gotcha.
So there's no way to
just leave the app on,
like say you're
doing a presentation,
and you want to let it go to
sleep while you're talking,
and then you open up and
then you want to swipe again?
JUSTIN KOH: So that's
where you would probably
use the notifications
that we showed
in the first part of this.
AUDIENCE: Oh, gotcha.
Gotcha.
OK, great.
Thank you.
AUSTIN ROBISON: Mhm.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: You guys
talked about the watch
as basically just a
remote control and the UI,
but what about when the watch
is providing like gyroscope,
or movements, and heartbeats
and things like that?
How are you dealing
with sensors?
JUSTIN KOH: So
remember that it is
Android running
on this wearable.
So you register a sensor
listener for the type of sensor
that you want to consume.
And then remember
that these APIs
are callable from both
sides of the link.
So you can collect sensor
data on the wearable
and then send it
to your instance
of your app running
on your phone.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned that
you can install discrete apps
on the phone themselves.
Right?
So how do you switch
between app to app?
Where's the menu, if
you will, or where's
the listing of all the apps
that you have on your phone?
AUSTIN ROBISON: So
the UI is really
designed to be post-grid.
So it is intentionally
missing that grid of apps.
So we encourage developers
to think about putting cards
into that stream
when they're relevant
or to register
for Voice Actions.
You can also say, OK,
Google, start app name,
and be able to bring that
application up on demand.
You can also get to that
through the cue card, which
is the touch menu when
you tap on the device.
AUDIENCE: So just a
follow-up question.
Are there preset voice
commands, or can you
define your own voice command?
AUSTIN ROBISON:
The voice commands
are part of the platform.
So on developer.android.com
there's
some documentation
that can tell you
how to register for the action
intents that are available.
We also would love to
hear your suggestions
for extending those actions
to other phrases or other use
cases.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUSTIN ROBISON: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: So it might be
related to the sensor question.
Can I get access to
voice time series?
JUSTIN KOH: For what
sort of application?
AUDIENCE: Say I want
to record memos.
JUSTIN KOH: You will
want to make sure
that the codec is
available on the device.
And there are
different codecs that
are available on
these devices than you
might expect from the phone.
So what we do for our
voice is we actually
stream the bytes using the
Message API over to the phone,
and then use the phone
to process the data.
Just to be more efficient.
AUDIENCE: As a developer,
I'm able to do that too?
JUSTIN KOH: Yeah.
So you can set up an audio
record and get raw bytes
and send those.
AUDIENCE: Perfect.
AUSTIN ROBISON: You can also,
part of the voice recognition
intent, if you
just want to record
and have us do the transcription
to get the string back,
but if you want the raw bytes,
then you can get the raw bytes.
JUSTIN KOH: But watch
out for the codecs.
AUSTIN ROBISON: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So my question is
about the way you
instantiate a lot of this stuff.
Everything you've shown here
touches activities and passes
in this.
Notifications tend
to mostly live
outside the activity
in my mind, right?
So the context that
your passing into,
does it have be an
activity, or can I
run it from a service
or an application?
JUSTIN KOH: It can
run from a service,
or yeah, the
application context.
In fact, using the
application context
is usually a good thing.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So a quick follow-up then.
Also about the bitmaps.
I mean, in my
experience, it's always
been so dangerous to play
with the byte arrays,
and especially
with BitmapFactory,
unless you're using
something like Picasa
to handle a lot of that for you.
So in your
recommendation, you're
saying go launch an
AsyncTask to the bitmap
stuff in the background.
Is there any
potential that you're
going to be working towards
offering an actual framework
around that to help us with
memory management, as opposed
to us having to rely
on outside sources?
JUSTIN KOH: Well, on
developer.android.com
there are a series
of developer articles
on dealing with large bitmaps.
For example, using
LRU caches, et cetera.
And that's our current
recommendation.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUSTIN ROBISON: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So my
question is about Glass.
Glass kind of seems separate
from all this wearable.
So if we're targeting Glass
and Android wearables,
do we need to develop
separately for that?
And GDK, the Glass SDK,
it seems not as capable
as this, what we just saw.
So what's the plan
to reconcile this?
AUSTIN ROBISON: Sure.
So the Wear team
and the Glass team
work very closely together.
In fact, yesterday we
announced that you'll
be able to take the
Android Wear notifications,
so the augmenting APIs, and have
those appear directly on Glass.
So we're absolutely
working together
to make sure that we have
a consistent set of APIs
across all of our
wearables in the company.
And there'll be
more coming soon.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So does Android Studio support
for wearables [INAUDIBLE]
here in different form factors?
Is that going to
extend to Glass as well
so we have one APK
that runs or that
has components that
support Glass as well?
JUSTIN KOH: It'll be one
project, multiple APKs.
And in the slide that I showed,
there is a check box for Glass.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you so much.
JUSTIN KOH: And I forgot
to mention this in my talk,
but yes, these are going to
be-- all Android projects,
you can create an
Android library
project to store shared code.
So in my example, I have
a presentation object
and a slide object that
I use on both sides.
I put that into an Android
library project and link
both of those from
my phone project
and from my wearable project.
AUDIENCE: Hi, yes.
I was wondering
if there is going
to be future support
for wearables
and connecting with Android
TV, or Android Auto,
other of those components for
connecting devices like that?
AUSTIN ROBISON: So
the same notifications
that I just spoke
about Glass will also
function with Android Auto.
So we are absolutely
thinking about this
as a pan-Android compatibility.
So we definitely are
working very closely
with all of those other teams.
We're working towards a
really compelling feature
that we'll be able to tell
you about in the future.
JUSTIN KOH: Right.
I think what's
important to note here
is that, like we said
yesterday in the keynote,
the phone is like your brain.
And so you can
control your phone,
and then your phone's
driving your TV,
or it's driving
your car, and that's
what really links
it all together.
AUSTIN ROBISON: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are we going to be
able to hard set the sample
rate and the
sensitivity for the IMU
that's on the wearable devices?
JUSTIN KOH: For the
what on the devices?
AUDIENCE: The IMU.
Like the accelerometer,
gyroscope, and compass.
JUSTIN KOH: You can
use the Android APIs
for setting the update rate.
AUDIENCE: OK, but I mean
the sensitivity itself.
Because the gyroscope
and accelerometer
have different
sensitivities built in,
and they are indicative
for different sort
of movement states.
AUSTIN ROBISON: If you
can do it on a phone,
you can do it on the wearable.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
JUSTIN KOH: Can you
do it on a phone?
AUDIENCE: No.
JUSTIN KOH: All right.
AUSTIN ROBISON: All
right, feature request.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Two small things.
Can you request
resources directly
from the internet
on the wearable,
or are they all just
passed through the device?
JUSTIN KOH: We recommend passing
it through the data layer.
And that's because we're
not supporting a full HTP
stack on the wearable.
AUDIENCE: I gotcha.
And do you get screen on, screen
off events from the wearable
as well?
JUSTIN KOH: You do.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And you could just
register for them
in the manifest or broadcast
receiver or something?
JUSTIN KOH: You can.
What are you trying
to do, though?
Sounds like you're
trying to do something.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
got an idea brewing.
JUSTIN KOH: All right.
AUDIENCE: Let you know after.
JUSTIN KOH: Sounds good.
Looking forward to it.
AUSTIN ROBISON: All right.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What do you
recommend for testing?
Will Espresso have support for
wearable for automated testing
or anything like that?
Or is there something coming up?
JUSTIN KOH: Is that like
a UI automation package?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the Espresso
and things like that.
JUSTIN KOH: We do use
uiautomators in our testing
internally.
So any of the same
tools that would
work on a phone or a tablet
would work on the wearable.
AUDIENCE: Do you need have
both the phone emulator
and the wearable running
or just one of them?
JUSTIN KOH: You
mean if you wanted
to set up like an
integration test
with like phone
talking to wearable?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
What do you guys recommend
for testing, I guess,
for those kind of things?
AUSTIN ROBISON: So there's
a couple different ways.
You can, with the
SDK, have your phone
connected to your
computer over USB.
That can either then
be communicating
with a wearable emulator, which
is a really good testing set
up, or you can have
it then communicating
with a real device, as well,
that can be connected over ADB.
So the support of having all
of those different devices
in different states
is there in the SDK.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
AUSTIN ROBISON: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
a way to stream audio
directly from the
wearable to the phone?
So if I want to make a
telephony app, I can do that?
JUSTIN KOH: Well, in the devices
that we announced yesterday,
there are no speakers.
So you'd only be able to talk
but not get anything back.
But I think there was an earlier
question about getting access
to the raw bytes.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But that won't be streaming.
Or can it be streamed?
JUSTIN KOH: Through [INAUDIBLE]?
We are streaming
in our application,
using the Message API.
AUDIENCE: OK.
That's it.
Thank you.
AUSTIN ROBISON: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you
talk a little bit more
about the existing new voice
commands and the process
will be for applying
for voice commands?
I was just trying to
check it out online,
and one of your voice
command pages gives a 404.
AUSTIN ROBISON:
The developer pages
are being updated
right now, or at least
they were before I got on stage.
There's a page on
there that will
list all of the
platform intents.
So there are I
think about a dozen
in there that support
things from call
a car, to start a
run, to take a note.
You register for those as you
register for any other intent.
If you'd like to
request more of them,
you can either speak with
your dev rel representative,
or you can go to
the G+ community,
where we'll have a form that
you can fill out to request
additional Voice Actions.
So that's +Android
Wear Developers.
AUDIENCE: So is that going
to be the same set of Voice
Actions we have
on Glass as well?
Because they have
their own voice
command application process.
Is that--
AUSTIN ROBISON: Today
they are separate.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUSTIN ROBISON: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
What is the AOSP story
for Android Wear?
AUSTIN ROBISON: You
want to take that one?
You know that one?
All right, I know that one.
OK.
So the parts of Android Wear
that are built on top of KitKat
and are built on top of
the existing AOSP parts
will be open source, just like
any other release of Android.
The Google Play services and
our proprietary first party apps
will not be open source, so
it's just like on the phone.
AUDIENCE: So I won't be able to
build my own AOSP-based phone?
Watch, I mean.
AUSTIN ROBISON: Correct.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so I think
this is great stuff,
and I appreciate the fact
that Google is thinking
about disconnecting
people from their devices
just so they can be
more human, basically.
But my question is this kind
of variable stuff still needs
the phone to be in proximity.
I want to know what happens if
the phone is not in proximity.
So one scenario would be let's
say I want to go for a run.
And I don't care about
taking calls or anything
at that point, but if a
friend texts me and says,
hey, I'm going to run
late for the next thing,
then I might want to see that.
Or might want to reply
that, hey, OK, I'm
going to take a longer
run, in that case.
Whatever.
So how does that
interaction happen
and if there is room
to do that right now,
or if there is a
plan for future?
AUSTIN ROBISON: So
today the devices
use Bluetooth for connectivity.
So when you are out of
Bluetooth range with your phone,
then you have no connectivity,
but you can still
access the data items that
are in your data store.
For example, you can
still do a few actions
on the device itself
through touch.
In the future, we
definitely think
about a connected constellation
of devices on your body.
So in the future, we
will explore this.
I think that's the direction
that the industry's going
in-- more and more connectivity.
There are power trade-offs
to be made here.
But it's definitely something
that we think about.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So just one question.
I mean, you said we can still
do a few things when it's out
of Bluetooth range,
but whatever I
do it's not going to--
I mean, if I, say,
send a text to someone, it's
not going to actually send it
because it can't
connect to the phone.
JUSTIN KOH: That's correct.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
OK, awesome.
Thank you.
AUSTIN ROBISON: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
following on the HTP stack,
I know this is basically an
Android Wear OEM agreement as
far as things like hardware
they have to support.
Are you guys going to
release-- can we expect a GPS?
I know heart rate is going
to be on some devices
but not on others.
I'm just curious as to what
specific hardware is going
to be guaranteed in every
Wear-compatible device.
AUSTIN ROBISON: So in
the beginning here,
having the accelerometer
IMU package is part of it.
The heart rate is
part of the platform.
It is optional.
And in the future, we will
be narrowing that down
and releasing more information.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Is there anything you can
mention today as far as GPS?
AUSTIN ROBISON: Not today.
AUDIENCE: Not today.
All right.
Thank you.
JUSTIN KOH: All right.
Last question, I think.
We're getting the
wrap it up signal.
AUDIENCE: You're going
to post the puppy app?
JUSTIN KOH: Yes.
I need to finish it.
I want to.
AUDIENCE: It's a good
point to start from.
Thanks.
JUSTIN KOH: We have
plenty of samples
as well, like with different
parts of the puppy app.
The puppy app kind of
draws them together,
but we have samples written by
some of our great team members
sitting here in
the front row which
will be targeted at some
of the different things
that we're doing.
AUSTIN ROBISON: All right.
Last last question.
JUSTIN KOH: Super last question.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned no
speakers on their thing,
but I'm wondering if you
guys have integrated talk
back so that it could
work on a device that
does have a headphone input.
AUSTIN ROBISON: Not today.
AUDIENCE: Will you be planning
on any kind of accessibility?
AUSTIN ROBISON:
Accessiblity is definitely
something that is very
important to the platform,
and we'll be improving upon
that in future releases.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JUSTIN KOH: All right.
AUSTIN ROBISON: All right.
JUSTIN KOH: Thanks, everybody.
AUSTIN ROBISON:
Thank you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]